bonjour et d'abord cette épouvantable
suspense à nantes au palais de justice
depuis plus de 24 heures maintenant
trois gangsters armés retiennent
toujours des otages dans ce tribunal il
y à quelques minutes ils ont relâché
cinq personnes nous venons de
l'apprendre
au total donc les neuf jurés ont tous
été libérés mais les gangsters
détiennent encore quatre otages quatre
magistrats alors tout de suite je vous
propose d'écouter un témoignage le
témoignage de notre confrère de radio
france joël bitoun il s'est rendu il ya
quelques instants à l'intérieur du
tribunal
à la demande des gangsters qui voulait
faire connaître leurs exigences
écoutez georges georges courtois ainsi
que les deux autres co co détenteur
si vous me permettez l'expression ont
demandé au haut parce qu'aux personnes
qui retenaient en otages de faire des
déclarations sur leurs conditions de
détention
après quoi les quatre femmes jurés ont
été libérés immédiatement
après on est passé aux déclarations et
des magistrats et des des hommes jurés
qui après leurs déclarations ont été ont
été également libéré je signale quand
même que je dois déposer rapidement
faire diffuser une déclaration de la
part de georges courtois dans à peu près
une demi heure
il tentera de sortir avec les quatre
derniers détenus à savoir donc les trois
magistrats plus le substitut varin et il
va tenter une sortie pour lui il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas de différence soit ils
parviennent à s'en sortir c'est relâche
et éventuellement la police soit
éventuellement il se suicideront et en
se suicidant ils détruiront également
les les otages qu'ils leur restent à
leur portée oui voilà cela c'était il ya
quelques minutes à peine je vous
rappelle que les otages qui restent sont
les quatre magistrats tous les jurés ont
été libérés et les gangsters semble donc
de plus en plus menaçant alors je vous
propose maintenant de revoir ce qui
s'est passé cette nuit
je vous rappelle d'abord que la prise
d'otage a commencé hier matin lorsque
trois gangsters donc ont pénétré en
plein tribunal
les événements de la nuit donc thierry
calmette
en fin de matinée la tante continue au
palais de justice de nantes les allées
et venues des policiers les rumeurs qui
circulent font désormais partie d'une
routine un peu angoissante
cette nuit on a cru plusieurs fois au
dénouement le quart a exigé par les
gangsters avaient pris place devant une
des sorties du palais puis s'était
déplacé en fait une fausse alerte en fin
de nuit on apprenait que la greffière du
tribunal avait été libéré discrètement
vers 6 heures du matin deux coups de feu
ont été entendus
apparemment pas de victimes des rumeurs
ont couru sur une tentative de sortie de
k line l'un des trois gangsters mais
aucune confirmation
si vous êtes oui oui il repassera tout à
l'heure on sent les négociations sur le
statut quo pour l'instant ils ont vu
s'exiler les journaux les gangsters
semble toujours vouloir se justifier
auprès des médias vers midi ils réclamé
la présence d'un représentant d'une
radio locale
à l'intérieur du palais de justice
voilà donc ça c'était ce qui s'est passé
ce matin et la libération de quelques
otages dans la matinée donc